we're told that a metal ball lies on a
flat horizontal surface
it is attracted by two magnets placed
around it
we're told that the first magnet's force
on the ball
is five newtons we're then told
the second magnet's force on the ball is
three newtons
in a direction that is one that is a 100
degree rotation
from the first magnet's force and we can
see that drawn here this is the first
magnet's force it's five newtons
and then the second magnet's force is
3 newtons at a 100 degree angle 100
degree rotation from the first magnet's
force
now they're asking us a few interesting
questions what is the combined strength
of the magnets pulls and then they also
say what is the direction of the
magnet's combined pulls
relative to the direction of the first
magnet's pull
so i encourage you pause this video and
have a go
at this on your own before we work
through this together
all right now let's work through this
together so they're really
saying if i take the sum of these two
vectors what is going to be the
resultant force vector what is going to
be the magnitude of that resultant force
vector
and what is it's going to be what is it
what is its direction
going to be there's two ways we could
approach this we could break down
each of these vectors into their
respective components and then add the
respective components and then
from that figure out what the magnitude
and direction is and we do that in other
videos
or we could take the geometric approach
so that's what we're going to do here
and to help us
with that we're going to use what we've
called the parallelogram rule which is
really the same idea
as the head to tail addiction of vectors
i could take the 3 newton
vector i can shift it over so its tail
is at the head
of the 5 newton vector it would look
something
like this so this is 3 newtons right
over there
and then i could also go the other way
around i could take the 3 newton vector
first
and take the tail of the 5 newton vector
at the head of the 3 newton vector
and shift it like this
you can add in either direction and
either way you look at it
when you start at the tails and you get
to the head of
the second vector you're going to have a
resultant force
that looks like this which is the
diagonal of
this parallelogram so there we go
and let me just call that our force
vector
right over there so if we can figure out
the length of
this line of this diagonal right over
here that would be the magnitude
of this force vector now how can we do
that
well let's just think geometrically what
else we can figure out
about what's going on over here this is
a parallelogram
so this is a hundred degree angle right
over here
this angle right over here is also going
to be 100 degrees
and we also know that these two opposite
angles
are also going to have the same measure
right over here and we also know
that the sum of all of the angles in a
quadrilateral are going to be
360 degrees so if these two make up 200
degrees we have 160 degrees
left that have to be split between that
one and that one so we know that this is
80 degrees
and we know that this is 80 degrees well
how does that help us
so we know the length of this brown side
we know the length of
this side right over here we know the
angle between them
and what we're trying to do is figure
out the length of the side
opposite this angle opposite this 80
degree angle
and some of you might remember the law
of cosines here
and the law of cosines i always imagine
it as
an adaptation of the pythagorean theorem
so that we can deal
with non-right triangles and the law of
cosines will tell us
that the magnitude i'll just write it
over here
the magnitude of this vector which is
the length of this diagonal
is going to be equal to the square root
of we're going to have
this side squared so let me write 3
squared plus this side squared
plus 5 squared minus
2 times this side
so times 3 times that side so
times 5 times the cosine
of 80 degrees and so let's get our
calculator out to calculate that
i'll start with taking the cosine of 80
degrees
then i'm just going to multiply that
times looks like 30.
so times 30 is equal to that
let's put a little negative there and
then
to that i'm going to add 25 and
9 which is 34 so
plus 34 is equal to that
and now i just take the square root of
all of that and they tell us to round
our answer to the nearest tenth so i can
round this
to approximately 5.4
so this is approximately 5.4
newtons now they say what is the
direction of the magnet's combined poles
relative to the direction of the first
magnet's pole so really what we want to
do is figure out
this angle right over here let's call
that theta
well we know what the length of the side
opposite is so maybe we could use
the law of sines the law of sines would
tell us that the sine
of theta over the length of the side
opposite to it
is going to be equal to let's pick
another angle we know
sine of this angle sine
of 80 degrees over the length of the
side
opposite to it and so this is
approximately
5.4 and so if we want to solve for theta
we can multiply both sides by three
so we're going to get sine of theta i'll
just stay in this purple color for for
simplicity
is equal to three times
sine of 80 degrees divided by 5.4
and then we could say that theta is
equal to the inverse sine
of all of this business 3 sine
of 80 degrees over 5.4
so we're going to take 80 degrees take
the sine of it
we're going to multiply that by 3
divide that by 5.4 that equals that
and then i'm going to take the inverse
sign of
all of that and they want us to round to
the nearest
integer so that's approximately 33
degrees
when you do the law of sines it's
possible that you're also dealing with
an
obtuse angle and when you do all of this
you get the acute one
and then you would have to make an
adjustment but that's not what we're
dealing here
so we know that this theta is
approximately equal to
33 degrees so we know the magnitude of
the force
and we know that it forms an angle of
approximately 33 degrees with the
direction
of the force of that first magnet